y una endoscopia del tracto
gastrointestinal inferior también
denominada colonoscopia o sigmoidoscopía
permite al médico visualizar las paredes
mucosas del tracto gastrointestinal
inferior
el procedimiento se utiliza como un
examen de diagnóstico en personas que no
presentan síntomas o para ayudar a
diagnosticar el dolor abdominal sin
explicación el sangrado rectal o un
cambio en los hábitos intestinales
permite detectar inflamación infecciones
úlceras diverticulosis estrechamiento
intestinal pólipos colorrectales cáncer
u otros problemas que se pueden
presentar
el procedimiento se realiza utilizando
un endoscopio que es un tubo flexible
delgado y largo con una luz y una cámara
de vídeo diminuta en el extremo la
cámara transmite la imagen a un monitor
en una sigmoidoscopía el endoscopio
sobre alcanza la parte superior del
colon descendente
en una colonoscopía el endoscopio se
extiende por toda la longitud del colon
hasta donde se conecta con el intestino
delgado
antes de someterse a una colonoscopia se
le colocará una vía intravenosa y se le
ofrecerán medicamentos para el dolor y
un sedante se controlará la presión
sanguínea el pulso y el nivel de oxígeno
en la sangre y es posible que también
reciba oxígeno mediante una cánula nasal
durante el procedimiento
generalmente una sigmoidoscopía no
requiere este tipo de preparación o
control
la presencia del endoscopio y el aire
puede provocarle calambres o presión y
puede tener gases esto se considera una
parte normal del procedimiento es
posible que el médico le solicite que
cambio de espacio de posición para
maniobrar el endoscopio más fácilmente a
través de las curvas del intestino
inferior si experimenta dolor avise al
médico inmediatamente en algunos casos
su médico puede considerar necesario
realizar una biopsia una biopsia ayuda a
distinguir entre los tejidos cancerosos
y benignos y puede ayudar a determinar
la causa del sangrado la inflamación o
la diarrea las biopsias por lo general
se realizan incluso si el médico no
sospecha de la presencia de cáncer si se
descubren uno o más pólipos el médico
generalmente los extraerá en un
procedimiento denominado polipectomía su
médico utilizará un lazo corredizo para
extraer los pólipos y luego que
autorizara sus bases para controlar el
sangrado después del procedimiento se lo
controlará durante media hora hasta que
ya no sienta los efectos del medicamento
que se le haya administrado necesitará
contar con alguien que lo lleve a su
hogar principalmente después de
someterse a una colonoscopia completa